et pour en parler nous sommes avec
olivier youinou infirmier anesthésiste à
l'hôpital henri mondor à créteil membres
du syndicat sud-santé ap-hp bonsoir
olivier oui nous merci d'être avec nous
191 cas ce soir
que disent ces chiffres sont bons vous
191 cas en france qu'on va
vraisemblablement passer à l'épidémie
stade 3 c'est à dire que alors qu'on
seriez encore les foyers n'est qu'on
pouvait distinguer les malades porteurs
qui contaminait aujourd'hui on va avoir
une
une épidémie sur l'ensemble du
territoire et on n'aura plus ces
contingents là on aura un virus qui va
circuler et qui va contaminer de plus en
plus de personnes ça c'est la vie de
réussira à maîtriser ses salons je ne
crois pas non je ne crois pas est ce
qu'on doit sont inquiétés traitement non
c'est toute la question c'est dire voilà
faut pas que ces mots fasse peur et me
condemi mais est-ce qu'on doit s'en
inquiéter selon professionnels que vous
êtes alors moi le professionnel constate
qu'on on est déjà inquiet et il ya une
peur une psychose qui s'installe dans le
pays autour de ce gros navires us croit
qu'il faut relativiser les choses
que ce soit sur la gravité de
l'infection elle-même et sur sa
mortalité par ce que il ya des
et il ya des maladies qui sont bien plus
mortel que ce que l'on va connaître là à
travers coronavirus donc relativiser
avoir un message plus apaisant peut-être
on a l'impression gens discutaient
encore en venant ici que chacun devient
un expert en santé parce que on va sur
les réseaux on regarde sur internet on
se fait sa propre idée et on devient un
diagnostiqueur un médecin en soi donc il
faut arrêter tout ça pour revenir à
quelque chose de plus sérieux que les
professionnels les infectiologues les
virologues nous dit ce qu'il en est
exactement de ce qui est risqué
les populations à risque et puis ce qui
vraisemblablement vont passer à travers
peut être contaminée peut être porteur
mais qui n'auront pas les mâts la ci de
là
le niveau grave de la maladie donc
essayer d'apaiser un peu le climat ça me
semble nécessaire aujourd'hui vous dit
juste titre la hongrie en gros vous
dites pas ça comme ça mais ça veut dire
la même chose on dit tout et n'importe
quoi chacun s'improvise experts vous
avez certainement pas tord mais enfin
c'est peut-être aussi parce qu'on sait
pas grand chose dont j'ai eu des grands
professeurs ici qu'ils ont dit bah en
fait on ne sait rien mais on ne sait pas
pourquoi les enfants sont pas à temps je
ne sais pas si avec la chaleur ça va
partir vous voyez il ya tous ces aspects
peut-être qu'ils nourrissent l'anxiété
on sait par contre que aujourd'hui la
mortalité n'est pas non plus celle que
l'on peut connaître par ailleurs il ya
moins de morts aujourd'hui par
coronavirus qui a par la grippe
saisonnière
alors les services il ya moins de morts
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ce qu'on nous dit l'inversé
de la grippe la grippe saisonnière c'est
8000 morts huit à dix mille morts par an
sur le territoire
on n'en est pas là encore aujourd'hui
l'épidémie va s'installer on va voir ce
qu'il en est mais les mesures de
protection sont les mêmes que pour la
grippe
quelles sont les populations c'est
peut-être ça que les spécialistes
doivent nous dire qui doit faire
attention est ce que lorsque l'on est
fragilisé par une infection pulmonaire
déjà c'est là qu'on est
et que l'on recense les cas de mortalité
il faut qu'ils nous disent aussi tous
ces cas où les patients sont infectées
par le virus et passe à travers deux des
fois même des symptômes ou qui se passe
dans coronavirus comme ils passent dans
une dans une grippe et s'en sortent très
bien
je crois qu'il faut essayer de donner
ces messages là à la population avant
d'en arriver à une psychose où chacun on
le voit déjà dans le métro pointe du
doigt l'asiatique en lui disant non je
veux pas discuter avec toi ou est très
suspicieux de qui à la moindre toux dans
l'est la proximité proche
ça veut dire que en clair ces mesures
parce que c'est tout simplement des
mesures qui nous viennent du
gouvernement qu'on est supposé tous
respectés quand on vient bon maintenant
sur la france aussi un vous me direz
mais quand on vient d'une zone à risque
saga pour l'asie au delà des pays d'asie
du sud est l'italie on doit garder ses
enfants à la maison ils ne peuvent plus
aller au collège au lycée c'est pareil
pour les salariés ils sont confinés chez
eux c'est peut-être ça qui nourrit est
ce qu elles sont excessives selon vous
ces mesures je sais pas si elles sont
excessives en tout cas on y revient pour
ne citer que le directeur général de
l'assistance publique il avait pris ces
mesures là il avait isolé et demander à
un confinement au domicile 50 de ses
agents il se pose la question
aujourd'hui est notamment pour prendre
en charge une éventuelle épidémie de
rappeler c
ces agents parce qu'ils sont
asymptomatiques et que s'ils portent le
masque
ça peut peut-être le faire il essaie de
raisonner aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut un
bénéfice risque et se dira peut-être que
des infirmiers des aides soignants même
contaminé avec un masque seront plus
utiles pour prendre en charge les
patients à l'hôpital que de rester chez
eux confiné en attendant
les résultats du test pour vous le
confinement c'est pas forcément le
prendre le bon le problème par la bonne
par le bon bout par d'euros a déjà été
choisi le confinement a été déjà choisi
comme mesure aujourd'hui on y revient à
moi c'est la question que je pose
il faut pas que ce soit pour des raisons
strictement économique que l'on revient
sur des positions que l'on a choisi a
priori en toute conscience en ayant pris
l'information auprès des professionnels
des infectiologues et les virologues de
notre institution notamment
qu'est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on
reviendrait sur cette décision l'agencé
rien peut-être que l'épidémie n'est pas
ce qu'elle
ou ce que l'on prétendait peut-être
qu'elle est moins grave que ce que l'on
dit encore j'en sais rien mais on a
besoin de cet éclairage là moi je ne
suis pas vous l'aviez dit en
introduction je suis pas un virologue ni
un infectiologue xian un infirmier
anesthésiste et j'ai pas cette
reconnaissance là
spécifique que ces spécialistes là nous
disent exactement ce qu'il en est
quelles sont les populations à risque
pour des développements graves de la
maladie et quelles sont les populations
très certainement plus nombreuses pour
lesquels juste de la prévention simples
le permettraient de passer le stade vous
dit vous n'avez pas cette expertise mais
vous en avez en revanche sur une autre
dont vous pouvez vous nous parler celle
du terrain du concret on a entendu
plusieurs médecins nous lire oui le
souci c'est que s'il ya une vraie
épidémie en tout cas si les gens sont de
plus en plus nombreux à être malade
le souci serait peut-être de ne pas être
avoir la capacité l'écran en charge
notamment les animations dans les cas
les plus graves
on l'a vu ça avec la fermeture de la
réanimation de creil et les
rapatriements des patients
vers les réanimations de l'assistance
publique il faut savoir aujourd'hui que
l'assistance publique a dit à 1000 lits
de fermer faute de personnel parce qu'on
n'arrive plus à embaucher à l'assistance
publique parce qu'on a contraint
financièrement notre établissement et
que aujourd'hui on est plus attractif
comme les professionnels ne viennent
plus travailler chez nous et on a fermé
1000 lits ça pose une problématique qui
vous comprenez bien qui va au delà de
l'épidémie coronavirus c'est n'importe
quelle épidémie qui arrive à n'importe
quelle situation exceptionnelle qui
arriverait aujourd'hui sur le territoire
en région parisienne pour ce qui est de
l'assistance publique
on ne sait pas si on est en mesure de
prendre en charge les patients comme ils
devraient l'être en qualité et en
sécurité parce qu'on a plus les moyens
et pour vous justement cette épidémie va
changer quelque chose dans votre combat
il y aura une tête une prise de
conscience pour espérer de cela en tous
les cas on espère beaucoup du changement
de ministre comme quoi une sextape
pourrait peut-être changer la situation
on espère aussi que
face à une épidémie de cet ordre là on
prenne conscience pas simplement les
professionnels pas simplement les
dirigeants pas simplement le
gouvernement mais la population de la
situation dans lesquelles l hôpital
aujourd'hui pour y remédier le plus
rapidement possible ça fait plus d'un an
que les professionnels sont dans des
mouvements sociaux réclamant non pas
pour eux mais réclamant des effectifs
pour prendre en soin correctement et
l'ouverture de lits quand la population
on a besoin et c'est le cas aujourd'hui
il est grand temps que le ministre parce
que la précédente ne l'a pas fait il est
grand temps que le ministre actuel
reçoivent les professionnels en
mouvement social depuis plus d'un an et
discute avec eux sur des négociations ou
vis des revendications portées je crois
que ce serait un message fort à donner
aujourd'hui aux hospitaliers sur
lesquelles on va encore compter sur leur
engagement leur dévouement leur vocation
ça suffit qu à un moment donné vous
savez on fait des heures supplémentaires
à n'en plus finir
on a mille deux cents jours un million
deux cent mille jours qui sont déposés
sur ce qu'on appelle des comptes épargne
temps et pour lesquels on n'a pas été
payé pas et qu'on n'a pas pu récupérer
et on nous dit encore aujourd'hui qu'on
va jouer sur les heures supplémentaires
de ses agents là pour reprendre en
charge l'épidémie ça suffit ça suffit
merci beaucoup olivier youinou d'avoir
été avec mon fils revienne et saisissent
membre également du syndicat sud santé à
l'hôpital henri mondor à créteil merci
merci à vous